this is going considerably better than
when I came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke I didn't mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent what's wrong I
got stopped by a cop last night not for
what stop for walking I make zero sense
unless
oh crap I see what happened yeah SARS
that's terrible that's so messed up oh
geez I have no idea what's going on he
got stopped for being black get woke
Scully wow that's good stuff who's your
guy actually it's a woman women can be
drug dealers too hashtag I'm with her
it's been a terrible year true but you
know what was rougher the hundreds of
years of Oppression experienced by black
people in this country oppression they
still experience to this day why does
Charles sound like a podcast oh because
I'm listening to one right now it's
called two wrongs makes a white lessons
in anti-racism yeah you're lucky you
weren't here on June 10th
what
what he went Fool's humor cultural
appropriation Amy she'll figure it out
you're the one who did it turns out he
didn't want to be best bros at all he
just wanted to know if I was cool with
him asking Amy out when the case ended I
thought he was in that weather girl now
he dumped her because she blamed
Hurricane Sandy on gay marriage anyways
now when the case ends Amy's gonna marry
detective blotter Dynamite why do you
even care you still like her I don't
know I mean we're friends
things have been kind of flirty lately
plus we have this weird romantic moment
thingy Charles and Gina's parents
wedding just say you still like her all
right fine I still like her
I'm thinking about asking her out for
the last couple of weeks but it's hard
so much build up now you know not really
I don't ask people that I just tell them
when we're going great well it doesn't
matter now anyway because I told Dave to
go for it that was crazy stupid
sorry that was normal stupid I should
have told him to back off I can't go
around telling guys not to ask Amy out
because I like her and I'm too dumb to
do anything about it I can't make a
woman's choice for her I stand with
Wendy did I do that right no you're
right I won't be as performative
I just donated to a great charity but I
won't tell you which one or how much
good for you
for black Trans women it was a thousand
dollars
what's going on oh nothing just had a
real eye-opening conversation with your
dad I wanted his approval but he says
I'll never be good enough for you what
the hell I know right
wrong no I'm upset with you that's bad
go get him tiger I'm also upset with you
what is this 1950 I can't date someone
unless I have my father's approval oh
obviously you can you guys act like this
is your decision to make like the woman
doesn't even exist in this equation well
this woman wait Amy shut up excuse me I
mean I'm so sorry you were making a
totally valid point about gender
equality but I just thought of something
really important so I'm gonna hang up on
you okay love you bye
it wasn't Russo or his sons
it was the daughter got Hal broke the
cop to every charge nice work Santiago
thank you sir for all to figure out the
pattern though so he should get credit
for the caller have you seen him I sent
him home he assaulted Jimmy Brogan yeah
but that caveman kind of had it coming
don't you think
oh
he didn't tell you tell me what never
mind if Jake didn't tell you he must
have had a reason it's not my place I'm
disappointed in you Santiago
I thought you and I were close
I know you're manipulating me
but I love it and I will tell you
anything
so Jake went to the schwitz to talk to
Brogan
ask you nicely as a fan of you your work
and the guys you wrote about
please don't print the quotes she didn't
realize you were gonna get your panties
all in a pretzel that's actually not
technically possible I'm not wearing
underwear I'm just swampy in here in my
butt's like the Everglades look I know
you're trying to be legit in a hairbag
world so I will not print your quotes ah
thank you thank you that means the world
to me and for the record I know that
Holt is a stickler but he's actually a
really good cop don't worry about it
we're friends you don't have to stick up
for that homo
I really wish you just said that wasn't
homo
thank you Santiago that'll be all
you thought I was just holds Lackey
well I'm my own person capable of making
my own decisions and I decided to
humiliate you both well you did and
it was awesome we're freezing in here we
want Heat we want heat we want heat
what I'm glad I gave them the megaphone
it helps me hear their concerns now if
you'll excuse me I need to go find a
couple bags of heat Charles and I
arrested a guy a couple of years ago
that was selling knockoff designer coats
just gotta find the box they're in and
everyone will be warm and happy you can
let them gang up on you you need to man
up man up sexist I'm sorry but I don't
see gender sir
so what'd you think of ropesberg
quaint it's whack and you know it
their number one crime is tricycle theft
there's a bakery attached to the
precinct come on Santiago you never
would have taken that job so why'd you
even care that they offered it to me I
can't help it I'm competitive
I have seven brothers and I was the only
girl I always had to fight for a place
at the table well you're not the only
girl at the table anymore
we work in a police force full of dudes
we gotta have each other's backs okay
saying you have my back yeah I got your
back
don't smile I'm still mad at you I
thought we were having a moment moment's
over shut up
something I'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go
I'm bisexual all right I will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go Amy how long have
you known since seventh grade I was
watching Saved by the Bell and I thought
Zack Morris is hot and then I thought
Lisa Turtle also hot the fact that the
words Kelly and capacity didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now Charles
found out on the road trip and I was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep the secret for much longer bye
version
I mean not bye but bye I mean see ya I
mean have fun only having sex with men
just banging dudes left and right I just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we're gonna look her up yes I am next do
you know Anne Heche I do oh I must say
this is going considerably better than
when I came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke I didn't mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent okay we have
time for one more question no no
absolutely not we're done
smart he was not tasteful if I was a
woman I would not work in finance oh
because it's so easy for women
everywhere else okay I can tell that I
am in trouble you're not in trouble I
just don't think that men understand how
different everything is for us I can
think of a million examples from this
week alone oh sick oh sick have a great
day oh thanks you too
you have a beautiful mom have a great
day Excuse Me Miss do you know where I
can find a police officer
uh sir you're a police officer right
yeah I'm a detective oh thank God I mean
you mean Unum oh that's why you yelled
that I thought you were just excited
about your general love of uniforms
usually when I yell that it is because
of my love of uniforms but not today
today it was because of that sexist jerk
God how many creeps have I not noticed
before oh no the fruit seller guy on our
corner is he a creep no he's a real
gentleman which is surprising because
he's always holding those two
cantaloupes and the opportunity to be
gross is right there I've never noticed
that before I never wanted to make a
comment or anything like that and I
thought better anyways I am genuinely
very sorry that this is something you
have to go through all the time it's
okay I'm used to it that's even sadder I
know but you know it's not sad that
Carrie didn't take that insane amount of
hush money now we get to put a bad guy
in jail amen wait her firm offered her a
big deal and you told her not to take it
yeah because that would mean letting a
sexual assaultier Go free do you have
any physical evidence to prove that he
did it no so it sounds like you might go
free anyway I mean at least it shakes a
deal she won't walk away with nothing
I'm surprised you feel like that you're
such a feminist I feel like maybe I
shouldn't be here I am a feminist but
I'm also a realist I'm just looking out
for the victim or every year
because men should be part of the
conversation let's just say best case
scenario you do find evidence she's
still gonna have to go through a very
public trial where they drag her name
through the mud even if she wins she
still loses it's two steps forward one
step back I've landed on active
listening I will no longer be jamming it
okay
wait where are you going I'm gonna go
get you a change of clothes and a coffee
we're not giving up
[Music]
reach out to all the co-workers again
privately maybe they didn't talk to us
because we interviewed them in their
office I think that's a great idea I'll
be right back oh I'm also going to grab
a comb but you don't have to use it
unless you decide
okay babe
Seth attacked me and I'm really proud of
myself that I didn't let him get away
with that so even though it sucks if I
had to do it all again I would
especially the broken penis
why'd she say that to me
oh